دكتور محمود يزبك الاكاديمي والخبير
بالشؤون الاسرائيليه دكتور محمود اذا نبدا
من
نقطه جنود الاحتياط ماذا يعني هذا العدد
الكبير من القتلى في هذه الفئه من
الجنود نعم يعني المفروض انه هذا الحدث هو
حدث كبير جدا بالنسبه لاسرائيل والاوصاف
التي تم استعمالها عند يعني لدى الرسميين
والاذاعات الاسرائيليه انه هذه كارثه
وطبعا يعني هذا المصطلح استعمال مصطلح
كارثه لا يستعمل بصوره يعني متواصله انما
ليعبر عن حدث هز المجتمع هز المؤسسه ككل
وهذا وهذا الحادث هو حادث حقيقه يعني هز
كل الصحافه الاسرائيليه كل الاعلاميين
الاسرائيليين وطبعا تاثيراته ستكون كبيره
جدا على المجتمع الاسرائيلي وسنرى ذلك انا
اعتقد في الايام القليله القادمه و بما
انه هؤلاء جدود احتياط فهم يمثلون عمليا
الشرائح المختلفه للمجتمع الاسرائيلي وا
في هنالك بين هؤلاء الجنود حوالي 20% هم
من ياتون من المستوطنات الاسرائيليه
المختلفه في الضفه الغربيه واخرين طبعا من
من مدن اخرى ولكن يعني في فحص سريع
لانتماء تهم الاجتماعيه لهؤلاء القتلى اي
نجد على انه في هنالك نسبه ليست قليله من
ممن ينتمون للاحزاب اليمينيه الاسرائيليه
هذا يعني باستطلاع سريع جدا
كان عملناه قبل قليل وهذا دليل على انه ما
رايناه في ليله ال في يوم البارحه في يوم
الامس انه بعد خروج مجموعه من جنود
الاحتياط من الجيش ويعني تسريحهم من جنود
من الاحتياط ذهبوا بسيارات الجيش وهذا كان
شيء غريب ومستهجن ووضعوا
لافتات على هذه السيارات على سيارات
الهامر العسكريه انه نحن نخرج من الجيش
نحن نصرح من الجيش دون ان يتم تحقيق
الاهداف التي جئنا لنحارب من اجلها بمعنى
انه هؤلاء الجنود حين تسريحهم وفي طريق
خروجهم من المعركه هم يضغطون على القياده
السياسيه العسكريه الاسرائيليه للاستمرار
بالحرب هذا يعني له دلاله كبيره جدا على
التغير الكبير الذي حدث في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ليس فقط من 7 اكتوبر انما في
السنه الاخيره يعني حينما بدات العمليه
الانتخابيه الاخيره وراينا انه المجتمع
الاسرائيلي يتجه يمينا اكثر واكثر والدليل
على ذلك هو الاحزاب اليمينيه المتطرفه مثل
حزب سموتريش ومثل حزب بنكبر الذي يعني
هؤلاء الناس هم الان يخدمون في الجيش
الاسرائيلي ولذلك انا اع اعتقد انه شخص
مثل نتنياهو مثل جلنت ومثل الاخرين في
القياده الاسرائيليه حينما تحدثوا قبل
قرير هم يعرفوا انه هنالك اداء صاغيه
لكلامهم في المجتمع الاسرائيلي لانه هذا
مجتمع يميني يريد استمرار الحرب و على ما
يبدو رغبه الانتقام عند هؤلاء لم تنتهي
بعد ولم تخف لانه هذه الحرب على ما يظهر
يعني بعد انه حوالي 110 ايام لا يوجد فيها
اي هد اخر الا الانتقام من مما يحصل في
غزه ولذلك هي ليست حرب لها اهداف محدده و
يعني اذا قرانا في جريده هارس اليوم على
الرغم من سقوط هذا الكم الكبير من الجنود
الاسرائيليين نعم هنالك من ما يسمى بقايا
اليسار الاسرائيلي مثل كاتب اسمه عامر
شوكن يكتب بانه نعم نتنياهو اخطا وهو الذي
يجر المجتمع الاسرائيلي الى حرب له فائده
منها فقط لمصلحته الشخصيه يكتب هذا ويقول
انه هؤلاء الذين سقطوا في المعركه اليوم
هم نتيجه سياسه خاطئه مخطوفه من قبل رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الذي يبحث عن مصلحته
الشخصيه هو وليس مصلحه المجتمع الاسرائيلي
و هب حاله الحنق او حتى الانتقادات موجهه
الى الجانب السياسي في اسرائيل ولا تطال
الجانب العسكري رغم ان حوادث السابقه وجهت
عبع الاتهام ايضا الى بعض الاجراءات
العسكريه ومنها ما يجري مع الاحتياط من
عدم التدريب الكافي وزجهم في المعارك دون
علمهم واعتراض وانسحاب بعض جنود الاحتياط
من
المعارك نعم هذا كلام صحيح 100% ولذلك
راينا ان هنالك قبل يومين او ثلاثه ايام
كان هنالك في رساله من بعض العسكريين
الاسرائيليين الذين يخدمون في الجيش يعني
من القياده العليا في الجيش الاسرائيلي
الذين كتبوا بانه هذه المعركه في غزه لن
تؤدي الى اي انجاز عسكري نحلم به ولذلك
ينصحون القياده السياسيه ان تتخذ قرارا
بعقد صفقه مع حماس وايقاف الحرب هذا كمان
شيء جديد يعني هنالك في تغيرات معينه في
منها الايجابي بالمنظور انه لوقف الحرب
وفي منها السلبي الكثير الذي ي يضغط من
اجل الاستمرار في الحرب ه هذا التناقض في
داخل القيادات والمجتمع الاسرائيلي يعني
لابد وان يؤثر في المجتمع كمجتمع ولكن هذا
التاثير حتى الان لم يصل الى مرحله النضوج
الكامل ليخرج الناس الى الشارع للمطالبه
وقف الحرب لانه هنالك على ما يبدو غالبيه
حتى هذه اللحظه في الشارع الاسرائيلي التي
لم تقتنع بوجوب وقف الحرب ولذلك هذا
الانقسام في القياده السياسيه و وفي
القياده العسكريه وفي المجتمع هو انقسام
في طريقه الى التطور ولم يصل الى المرحله
النهائيه التي ممكن ان نقول انه الان بدات
خطوه جديده نحن في طريق الخطوه الجديده
ولكن لم نصل بعد الى هذا يعني ال الطريق
او نهايه هذا الطريق استمعنا ايضا الى
جهات نعم الى جهات اخرى يعني غير البيان
الثلاثي هذا لقياده الحرب اي من لابيد
مثلا اي ك كزعيم للمعارضه هل قرات مواقفا
بناء على هذه الحوادث ومسار المعركه ايضا
تلعبها المعارضه هل قرات مواقفا مختلفه
متطوره في هذه اللحظه يعني لا يمكن لاي من
القيادات السياسيه
الاسرائيليه ان كان المعارضه او غير
المعارضه ان يقف يعني في صف يختلف عن صف
نتنياهو من ناحيه الوقوف الى المجتمع
والتعزيه و نحن معكم وقلوبنا معكم ومثل
هذا الكلام سننتظر يوم او يومين
وعندها سنرى كيف تفاعلت القيادات السياسيه
المعارضه والقيادات المجتمعيه والصحفيه ال
يعني ما يسمى المركز وليس اليمينيه كيف
تتفاعل مع هذا الحدث لابد ان هذا الحدث
يعني حدث طبعا له اثره الكبير على المجتمع
الاسرائيلي على السياسه الاسرائيليه ولكن
مثل ما تعودنا على المجتمع الاسرائيلي
والقياده السياسيه ل الاسرائيليه لا تخرج
مباشره الا القليل الا اليساريين القله
اليساريين الذين يخرجون مباشره في هذا
الظرف بالذات ويقولون كلمتهم بحق ولكن
الغالبيه العظمى من القيادات الاسرائيليه
ستصمت ل خال يوم او يومين حتى ينتهوا من
دفن هؤلاء وبعد ذلك سنسمع تصريحات جديده
التي انا اعتقد ستغير يعني قد يكون هذا
الحدث هو بدايه تغيير حقيقي في المواقف
السياسيه الاسرائيليه على الاقل لدى
المعارضه الاسرائيليه مثل هذا الحدث لا
يمكن ان يمر مر الكرام دون ان يعني يعني
يؤدي الى هزه كبيره في المجتمع الاسرائيلي
وهذا ما قراناه في التصريحات نفسها حينما
يستعملون كلمه كارثه هذا المصطلح لا
يستعمل الا في حاله انه الحدث كبير جدا
ولذلك حتى يا نتنياهو جلن جانز كلهم
استعملوا مصطلح كارثه وحتى الصحافه
الاسرائيليه يعني المحايده تقريبا مثلها
ار استعملت كذلك هذا المصطلح مما يدل على
انه هناك قضيه عميقه جدا حدث عميق جدا ولا
بد ان نرى تاثيراته في الايام القليله
القادمه دكتور محمود يزبك شكرا جزيلا لك